[Musique]
arrête de le fixer venez boir avec nous
il faut que vous m'aidiez vous aidez
mais comment je suis enseignant donz ça
à votre ditesle que c'est un cadeau de
la part du numéro 1 du blanchiment
d'argent de la mafia
russe c'est tout ce qu'il vous a donné
il vous dit qu'il fait partie de la
mafia russe vous jeens cl termin il a
dit que si je pas
en politicien avoc anglais par les r à
lras pour lui et
FAM le problème ve négocier avec nous
vre prés je pas
êrequj su pour Moscou pour le je sais d'
vient l'argent je veux la preu que
toutes ces personnes tou des
commissions
où est-ce que vous les cacher il veut
qu'on fasse quitter le pays à sa famille
rien d'autre je ne peux pas garantir
votre sécurité il ne vous lâcheront
pas perd pas de temps
alors l'argent n'a pas d'odeur tant
qu'il coule à flot mais ça reste
l'argent du sang ni plus ni moin vous
avez trahi votre pays pourquoi vous MZ
choisi
[Musique]
stop staring come a drink with us I need
your help help you what can I do i'm a
teacher give this to your mi tell them
you have a gift from the number one
money launderer from the Russian
Maia this all he gave you he was a
member of the Russian mafia and you
still agreed to help him I thought I
could just hand it over and be done with
it he said that his children would be
killed if I
didn't British politicians lawyers and
bankers recruited by here in London what
does he want ass for himself and his
family trouble is'll only deal with us
if you there and Paris I can't get
involved I'm afraid you are
involved i'm a threat to mosc to I know
where the money comes from I need proof
that all these people are being
paid hiding getting his family out all
matter to him they kill them I can't
guarantee your safety they'll be coming
after
you then you better
hurry money has no smell as long as
there's enough of it doesn't change
color it's still Blood Money beted your
country why did you choose
me